let me
let me change the conversation and give
people a bit of a white pill yeah it's a
little little scary conversation we're
talking about is crazy stuff but i have
a story about the waning power of the
establishment yes an interrupting
scandal over at everyone's favorite
network cnn in this story from
timcast.com cnn president jeff zucker
announces resignation
zucker says he failed to disclose a
relationship with a colleague to the
media company but oh boy is it so much
spicier than that
we have this story from the daily mail
devastated cnn hosts defend
jeff zucker's illicit career-ending
affair with staffer allison golust brian
stelter blames chris cuomo for outing
him while allison camerota says he
should not resign
well this is a really fascinating chris
isn't done yet cuomo's lawyer demand to
see emails they believe will prove jeff
zucker knew about his help for andrew
his brother andrew that could cost the
former cnn chief millions of dollars
after sacked host forced him to resign
all right let me let me let me uh bundle
this up for you guys first of all cnn's
ratings are just in the total trash
so the the the tim poole tim cass
podcasts get more viewership than cnn
does by like two or three times that's
how that's how bad cnn's doing
what happens is jeff zucker
you you've got uh jeff sucker who knows
this woman allison uh what's her what's
it what's her lust go lust for 20 years
wow she works for andrew cuomo right
then she leaves to go work with him in
cnn
chris cuomo is then trying to help his
brother with this big scandal they cover
it up
chris cuomo gets caught doesn't get
reprimanded all of a sudden we're now
learning that they're all in it together
they're all one big happy family jeff
zucker then comes out fires chris cuomo
chris cuomo it seems feels betrayed like
yo what are you doing like come on man
you know allison she worked with my
brother and we helped you out so then he
then he publicly he comes out and he
says
zucker was in a relationship with her
and he didn't disclose it so then he's
forced to resign i think there's a
bigger scandal behind all of this
because this shows that cnn is directly
colluding with democratic politicians
democrat politicians
so that's i think there's more to it
than just this and we're just getting
the tip of the iceberg on this one but
cnn
imploding in real time from their top
hosts to the present of their company to
the connections they have with
democratic establishment all being
exposed
let that be a good day for all of you to
see the just the eruption in front of
your in front of your very eyes if they
cnn was a prime vector for russia gate
misinformation for ukraine gate
misinformation and now
and kavanaugh and all that stuff and
defensive blm uh rioting and all that
stuff
not only does nobody watch them anymore
but they can't they can't even keep the
the ship together it's sinking baby
that's beautiful i'm here so
how many views do they get
so uh i looked up this is totally
independent of these stories i looked up
their ratings their total daytime
viewership
443
000 viewers i believe it's number no and
their total prime time viewership is 663
so daytime's usually way lower but this
is a lot daytime's a lot a lot of hours
but prime time is when everyone's tuning
into the news so they're only getting
just over about a million views but get
this they only get around 230 000 key
demographic views
per day
230 000 people between the ages of 25 to
54 watch cnn on a given day that's it
that's that that's how abysmally so i
was saying this before the show i was
like yo
one segment that i do that we do so on
my tim cats news channel we average like
250
unique views
and key demo views one segment i do on
my channel gets more than cnn's total
key demographic daily viewership
sheamus said to me he's like stop
bragging and i said no no no it's not
because i'm doing well it's because
cnn's collapsing no no and tim does all
that without any sex scandals either and
like
these people can't even get a fraction
of the viewership without doing
something creepy no but it's true i mean
uh it is kind of remarkable to see how
abysmal their views are and it's it's i
mean it's also a white pill i'm not
really yeah i don't want to get too too
down on zuck zuck zucker for this one
because i think he really loved that
girl i mean they've been together for 20
years is that right no no no no no no no
no no they've known
or won't they kind of thing for a while
escape the friend
zone was that joke you had earlier
sheamus i don't remember you were like
uh he said that he should have revealed
the relationship sooner and didn't and
you were saying like the judge oh my
gosh yeah no she was like
it was a miscommunication she talked to
management was like he was like you know
we're just like talking it's not you
know i mean he wouldn't define the
relationship and she's like well i know
who will well no yeah you were saying
like i'm gonna tell cnn the manager goes
to jeff zucker and says are you in a
relationship with this woman and then
she turns it
the executive's like so what are you
guys she's like yeah jeff what are we
like what's uh what's this he's like oh
and then he's like
just zooming on his face real slow yeah
you know this is this is a ridiculous
scandal i think i think he's like is
this like an easy pass for him to get
out yeah well he wanted to quit but
here's the crazy thing they were saying
this woman um this this woman uh alison
gallusta our goalist was going
to go lust was potentially going to
replace him as president
so this was months ago earlier last year
they they were like
you know she may be tapped to be the new
president when he steps down because he
was talking about leaving for some time
and all of a sudden he's leaving because
the whole thing is imploding yeah so if
nobody watches cnn where do they get all
their money from i'm genuinely curious
you know subsidy but is isn't it also
completely insane
isn't it completely insane that the
people who make all of their money lying
all the time don't conduct themselves in
an upright manner in their personal life
yeah that's so bizarre who would have
thought i would think they'd be honest
who would have thought that like you
can't trust people who you can't trust
people are calling for brian selter to
be fired or quit resign why because he
was he avoided reporting on this this
ongoing major scandal at his own network
that people have known about for some
time well he feels sorry for you was
that him during the project veritas
video and therefore he's like i feel
sorry for you i feel sorry for you brian
stelter i believe it was stelter
they confronted him in like it was a
parking garage somewhere when you're
yeah he's like i feel sorry for you i
feel sorry for you just trying to get
away super condescending when you arrest
a murderer you don't cut off the finger
that he used to pull the trigger that's
stelter's the finger
well cnn's though is the villain yeah
yeah well no i'm kind of joking because
you could always terminate uh brian
stelter can you imagine if he did report
that story on air though
the president of this company my boss is
in a secret relationship with the chief
marketing officer everyone here knows it
but no one's saying anything because
we're scumbags i feel sorry for them
yeah i feel sorry for them look the
bigger the bigger story is that cnn is
one of the principal propaganda machines
and it's just like we are sitting we're
sitting on the here here's what i want
you i want you all to imagine this
it is a warm summer night we're all on
the beach
there's a nice fire going right that's a
nice fire going it's it's it's not too
warm and uh you know your friend reaches
over puts their hand on your shoulder
and hands you a nice cold beer and you
all look off into the shoreline and you
see a gigantic [ __ ] that says cnn just
sinking and in flames
yeah and then everyone holds up there
what a great night that's like all right
first of all i cannot condone that kind
of thing that's really funny do you
remember when someone made a meme of
where they like photoshopped the cnn
logo onto a wrestler's head and trump
was punching it and sienna literally
this kid and then they reported on their
own boxing thinking it made them look
good they're like yeah we found him
he'll never do this again we feel sorry
for him they didn't docks and
if he agrees to never do it again we
won't release his name and everyone was
like yo
crazy crazy didn't chris wallace just go
to cnn yeah i seen him that was that was
a good move well he was just like i
would like to jump on that circle
and then he did perfect timing yes okay
you know i i i wake up in the morning
and i get out of bed i turn on the
keurig and it pours me we use
biodegradable curry cups they're very
it's true they're disgusting
i think it's fantastic and then i get my
coffee and i put some cream in it and
then i take a sip and then i walk over
and i walk over to my computer and i
press the button turn the screensaver
off and i see big story you know cnn
ratings in the gutter racked by scandal
and i just look up i say
it's going to be a good day oh yeah
[Laughter]
and i get to work and
oh man it feels good it does because no
it does it's really it's really yeah
it's really frustrating to see uh you
know we can talk about the joe rogan
thing where brian stelter is like we
have a newsroom and we try so hard and
people just trust joe rogan cause they
don't trust us it's like oh poor baby
you know i love to see it you love to
see it man you guys they lied every
every day about russia they staged they
staged chris cuomo's quarantine they
pretended he was in quarantine they lied
they know they lied brian stelter knows
they lied these people are evil their
actions are intentional we all know it
and we are all gloating in their
glorious sinking ship well it's more
than that watching their glory yeah
we're watching it saying here's the
other thing though it's not as if they
just lied right they have never
acknowledged or apologized for any of
those lies even though they scolded you
for believing that they were lying the
entire time that they were lying and so
i'm not just watching this gloating i am
genuinely happy that there are fewer
people consuming their lies i want to
give a shout out to our good friend
michael malus he says white pill after
cnn decided to take on joe rogan both
the president and most popular host were
driven out of their jobs
mess with joe you gotta go
there you go i love it that's perfect i
love when people are saying uh denounce
the honk and you get the bunk uh yeah
cause that's the conservative leader got
outside whatever yeah you're good mottos
well i think this is so ian was saying
before the show that he didn't really
want to cancel people like cnn and i
think that um this is actually a form of
actual justice not social justice that's
right because they've done nothing but
lie we know they've done nothing but lie
you can see chris cuomo coming up out of
his basement when we know for a fact
that he was in a fight with a guy on a
bike in the hamptons two weeks before we
know he wasn't quarantining we know
they're all lying they're just full of
garbage and this is finally come up it's
for them and yes it does feel good
yeah that's true
he said that was like the n word for
italian exactly it is it's not but it's
very nice
it's like very much not it's not even
close you're dumb
oh man so cnn lied over and over again
claiming that joe rogan took horse
medicine they all know they lie yeah and
when i see these posts on facebook
they're like joe rogan took horse
medicine and then i comment i'm like you
know he didn't right like you know a
doctor prescribed him tablets and
they're like yes but the medication in
the tablets the same medication they use
for horse medicine so i was just making
slight point you know you're lying dude
yeah like what what what what into his
mouth is horse medicine what comes out
of your mouth is horse crap all the time
literally never an honest word fire
also wait that there's something there's
yeah yeah fair enough there was
something i wanted to mention here um
but my train of throat thoughts good
duration
of throat my train of thrones oh no i
just want to say one thing about
with ian to be fair ian kind of turned
around on that point before the show
about cancel culture one thing that
drives me crazy uh is this left-wing
talking point where they say cancel
culture is just about accountability
even though they're just trying to get
like average working-class people fired
from their jobs or political activists
they don't like punish for things they
said 10 years ago and then when we're
against cancel culture any time we want
someone to be punished for an actual
crime they go oh i thought i thought you
guys were against cancer you think you
think people should be punished for
actual crimes that they've committed or
should be thrown out of the organization
they're right for actually breaking the
rules i thought you were against cancer
i thought you were against firing people
for 10 year old tweets what's the deal
we hypocrisy much yeah thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you